hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round 11 of this year's
Global chess League it is the SG Alpine
Warriors versus the shingari golf Titans
uh the the Alpine Warriors led by Magnus
Crossen and the golf tile enslaved by
Young shisto of Duda they already played
once in the first half of the tournament
their game ended in a draw in round four
and now Magnus will try his luck with
the wine pieces it's a fine game uh due
to sacrifices the exchange for uh you
know a weirdly active position or maybe
it's an actively weird position you guys
will be the judge of that as usual uh
but all in all very nice active game so
let's check it out that Magnus has the
wine pieces and he opens with Ponte E4
Duda goes for the Sicilian Defense with
Pawn to C5 Knight to F3 D6 and of course
Knight to C3 not going for D4 right away
we have Knight to F6 Bishop to E2 and
Bishop T2 sort of an uh offbeat move
um you could uh well it's maybe like the
seventh most popular continuation but we
transpose into the main line very
quickly so the doesn't really matter
Knight to C6 with Pawn to D4 captures
captures and now Ponte E5 shifting it to
the
variation of the classical Sicilian with
Knight back to F3 Knight the B3 a bit
more popular but here we have Knight to
F3 upon the H6 and now casts with Bishop
D7 by Duda and Rook to E1 we have
castles and now Bishop to F1 it's a very
uh very uh standard move that frees up
the file for The Rook now D4 Pawn is
nicely defended but you will see just
how useful this bishop on F1 is and it
seems like a very passive Square for the
bishop but uh you know it definitely
gets the job done so Rook the E8 and now
Pawn to H3 and there is one game where
A6 was played here maybe 20 33 years ago
I think uh but here we have Bishop to f8
and it is now as of movie 11 that we
have a completely new game
that's okay Magnus plays uh upon the B3
he wants the film Captain his dark
Square Bishop uh we have A6 and a bishop
to B2 Duda continues to his expansion
with Bishop Pawn to B5 Queen to D2 now
preparing to bring the Rooks into the
game and Bishop to B7 fiancato in the
light Square bishop and now Knights the
D5 another standard anti-sicilian move
with Knight captures um on the 5e
characters on D5 and Knight D7 now
putting pressure on the D5 pawn and
Magnus defends it with Pawn to C4 and
now the C4 Pawn is nicely defended by
the B3 pawn and by that Bishop on F1
that we've tucked in for later use we've
Queen to D7 uh developing the queen
connecting Rooks and now Pawn to a for
putting pressure on that B5 Pawn uh of
course hoping that Duda captures an A4
then your C4 Pawn is uh looking very
strong now Duda could maybe throw in a
nice Rook uh Rook to C8 but he goes for
B captures and C4 first B captures and
C4 and now Knight to G6 now you can play
E4 you can play F5 E4 you can play F5 F4
all depends on what white plays Ponte A5
Magnus grabs more space on the queen
side and now we have Rook 8 to C8 as The
Rook uh really has no more use on the uh
a file uh Bishop to A3 not just
controlling this diagonal but also
preparing to shift the Rook over to the
B file because the B file is at the
moment the only open file on the board
we have Pawn to E4
uh grabbing more space in the center but
also allowing Magnus some squares now
the D4 square has been vacated and of
course Magnus will happily use it as an
outpost for his Knight with Knight to E5
Duda also created an outpost for his
Knight and Rook 8 to C1 and now we have
Quinta A4 putting pressure on the bishop
and this is uh of course when you look
for moves uh the Knight really doesn't
have a better move it looks beautiful
there the bishop for a moment has no
squares The Rook is fine on C8 this Rook
is finally eight the bishop has no moves
on f8 so the only piece you have left to
improve is the queen and that's how you
uh you know when you have a lot of moves
um that you are considering always try
to you know uh improve your worst piece
the most then that move is accomplished
by playing Queen to A4 so here uh of
course the bishop is hanging Magnus
defends it with Bishop to B4 and now
Knights the D3 this is a possible as you
will not be losing a pawn since the
queen cannot be attacking the pawn and
also defending the bishop so while you
don't want the Knight here as it's
attacking both of the Rooks Magnus does
capture the Knight he captures on D3 and
now Rook e to D1 now Magnus has to
figure out how to safely capture the
d-pawn and then he's just gonna be up
upon we have worked the C7 now you can
double up on the E file but also put
more pressure on that C4 Pawn uh Knight
to the F5 by Magnus uh very very
unpleasant and not Bishop to C8 uh
putting pressure on the Knight and now
just Knight back to E3
uh the point is that the C4 Pawn is now
nicely defended uh twice uh but also you
can just move the Rook here now you're
gonna play Rook day one attack the Queen
Once the queen moves you safely pick up
the D3 pawn and you have a better
position and here Duda uh could continue
with something like F5 objectively this
is the safest way to go uh point is that
after the the said the variation is
played Rook day one Queen to D7 now you
pick up the pawn here you can play Pawn
to F4 and you've won some space here on
the king side you could win the knight
from E3 now it goes to F1 and maybe you
have maybe you have something here
however Duda decides to go for the
exchange sacrifice that we mentioned in
the beginning of the video and plays
Rook captures on E3 and now how does
Magnus continue well if he just takes
the Rook with uh you don't want to
capture with the queen of course then
the bishop hangs but you can play F
captures on E3 this somewhat weakens
your king but also after Bishop to F5 uh
you don't have E4 and the the D3 uh Pawn
is defended so this would be very good
for uh dooda Magnus instead does not
capture The Rook right away he plays a
rook the A1 and he allows Luda to play
Queen captures on A1 and it's uh again
objectively maybe the best thing to do
you've already grabbed material magnets
did not capture back
uh why not take the Rook if Queen
captures an A1 Rook captures and now
okay your Rook is hanging you move the
Rook let's say queen captures on D3 The
Rook will capture the opponent C4 and
after Bishop to C3 you will play
something like Bishop to F5 you have the
Rook pair you have the bishop pair uh
you have uh definitely a fighting chance
here but after Rook to A1 dude decided
to go for Queen to B3 and now Magnus
again should capture here but he goes
for Rook 8 to B1 again allowing Duda to
go for Queen captures on B1 but okay
dude already decided he doesn't want to
do that uh he played Queen captures on
C4 and only not Magnus captures an E3
but now with the queen as The Rook is
guarding the bishop on B4 so Queen
captures an E3 and now Bishop to F5
finally do this uh well uh the bishop
that was pretty useless on B7 now comes
very much alive on this diagonal
uh we have Rogue beat the C1 uh you do
not want to see D2 being made with a
discovery so Rook to C1 first attacks
the queen and now uh you could go for
Queen captures on B4 it's definitely an
option you could um give up even one
more exchange and then Queen captures on
A5 and you would have the bishop pair
against The Rook pair but you would have
to pass the d-pawn ended the past a pawn
uh again it is some some compensation
objectively white is of course better
but it's rapid uh you know who knows
what might happen uh in the game Queen
the B3 was played by Duda and now we
have Rook captures um on C7 Queen
captures on D1 with check King to H2 and
now Queen back to B3 putting a pressure
on the bishop here and Magnus finds the
strongest continuation that is Queen to
D4 now the thread of course is Bishop to
C3 and you wanna put pressure on that uh
King later on you can put the Rook on A7
attack the pawn for the rook and A8
pressure the bishop and then black will
definitely have problems so do that
needs to figure out how to stop Bishop
to C3 he plays Queen to A4 now of course
if you move the bishop you can trade
Queens uh and Rook the A7 goes after the
pawn and uh okay Duda does have the
bishop pair but uh it's not really doing
all that much you cannot Advance the
pawn so
now you know it's it's not as great uh
of course the bishop cannot capture but
the queen can capture and guards the
bishop so that's the point uh Bishop to
G6 was played and now Rook to A8 there's
always time to capture on A6 so what you
really want to do uh is pin that Bishop
uh we have Queen to D7 uh and now comes
Queen to B6 uh we have Queen to F5 and
now Magnus is of course completely
winning uh so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for Magnus uh
while I give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those who were able to do it
congratulations on realizing that the
king is almost getting checkmated and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is of course a rook captures
and if uh an f8 uh this is what Magnus
player you could also play Queen
captures on D6 to put pressure on the
bishop all of this works nicely uh
Magnus played Rook captures on a f8 and
while you can resign here uh Duda found
that there is uh at least a little bit
of poison left in the position and he
decided to continue of course you cannot
capture if you capture his Checkmate uh
that you know everyone can see but if
King the H7 uh now uh you can easily
mess it up Magnus played Queen to D4 and
that was it but the point is if Magnus
played something like Queen to d8 which
would threaten Checkmate and okay Europa
Rook you're threatening Checkmate life
is good this is actually a dead draw
because now Queen to F4 leads to a
Perpetual if you go down the board we
have a Perpetual here uh Queen checking
the H2 Queen to F4 with check and of
course if you play G3 then you just get
uh checkmated mate into you with the
bishop on e4 so yeah Magnus of course
spotted that after King to H7 he said
nope do that you are not tricking me
Queen to D4 and he was in this position
on move 40 that Yang shishito Duda
resigned to the game and a very nice win
for Magnus Carlsen in round 11 of this
year's Global chess league so now these
two squares have been taken you don't
have checks uh that's it Magnus is just
up a full rook and that is that let me
just quickly check uh how the the team
played uh here yeah it seems sorry about
that yeah it seems to be 3-3 yeah but no
uh as the milk came Magnus one and uh
with the white pieces Batman defeated
gookish with black and all the other
games were drawn obviously the golf
Titans have defeated the Alpine Warriors
as the momodoros win with the black
pieces against gukash is worth more than
magnus's uh win with the white pieces
over Duda so again we have a win on
first board but a loss for the team
which seems to be happening quite a lot
in this tournament uh but yeah that's
the game I hope you guys enjoyed it uh
do the played a very nice active game
game
um yeah he sacrificed The Exchange but
probably at that moment where Magnus
allowed him to go for the queen
sacrifice where he played rook's Rook
day one he should have gone for Queen
capture Sun A1 and then probably it's a
completely different game uh with the
position being something like this okay
you have the bishop Perry and The Rook
pair uh this is definitely still a game
but uh you know due to decline the the
the possibility of sacrificing the queen
twice and that was uh it's probably not
even the reason that he lost the game
but it just led to a worse position to
worst position to a worse position and
then in the end you know he just lost uh
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
if you have any favorites do use hashtag
suggestion I will go over your
suggestions as always and gladly show
the games I would like to thank Jim
Meadow too yunyang Federico Torres
Velasco Dan McCormick and James Eugene
Cashman for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on you wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day